[Musique]
durant ce mois d'octobre des réunions
d'information sont organisées aux quatre
coins de l'île en direction des
bénéficiaires du rsa
un partenariat entre le département et
les acteurs concernés autour des
opportunités professionnelles offertes
par les métiers de l'aide à la personne
et le dispositif départemental est plus
aujourd'hui ce partenariat s'est
communiquée ce une réelle opportunité en
matière d'insertion durable qu'on parle
de insertion durable c'est un parcours
qui va de la formation jusqu'à la
reprise d'activité et avec le
partenariat qu'on a construit avec le
cfa rcs à la personne qui a été créée
par département aujourd'hui on a une
opportunité de toucher plusieurs
centaines de personnes me sers du rsa
qui peuvent avoir une appétence en lien
que c'est toi c'est ça la personne et
dans ce cadre là le département
s'inscrit pour les accompagner vers leur
parcours d'insertion pour qu'il puisse
réussir
l'aide à la personne une filière à forte
potentialité 400000 emplois ont été
créés dans ce secteur ces dix dernières
années en france dont plus de 18000 à la
réunion en fait la fedesap donc proche
de ses adhérents a besoin de bras et
donc on nous avons pris conscience qu'il
fallait former et accompagner le plus de
personnes possible et de présenter nos
métiers au public plus large et donc de
ce fait on a décidé avec le conseil
départemental de la réunion de faire une
opération importante pour rencontrer les
personnes bénéficiaires du rsa pour leur
présenter les métiers de services à la
personne espérer les former à la réunion
et peut-être les employés la réunion
sûrement mais aussi peut-être les faire
venir en métropole en cas de la mobilité
les bénéficiaires du rsa pourront ainsi
se former et évoluer dans les métiers du
service à la personne
au moins aller plus loin
awan formation ça peut travailler les
hanter le soap récompense moi c'est plus
pour les enfants la dre ou de
surveillance c'est un partenariat mis en
place dans le cadre du dispositif
r plus l'allocation d'insertion et de
retour à l'emploi qui permet de cumuler
allocation et revenus d'activité
[Musique]